and he starts off this hour in Kansas
hey Andy welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
any day thanks for taking my call
sure man what's up well I'm looking at
retiring from the military here shortly
I've got 23 years in and we we didn't do
the Dave Ramsey plan but luckily we have
pretty much been debt-free most of our
marriage and the only thing we have is
our house so I've been trying to
convince my wife to take some of our non
retirement savings that are in mutual
funds and sell them and pay off the
house but it's a really hard sell and
I'm I guess I'm wondering if I'm just
pushing too much and I should just
compromise and you know just start
paying it off as much as possible each
month how much do you owe on your home
we owe that 160 and how much do you have
an on the tournament mutual funds about
800 okay and what is her reasoning she's
she I think is nervous about the loss of
the interest that we would gain from
keeping that investment going how much
do much was your home worth it's worth
about 340 okay if we're gonna go with
her theory we would have to in order to
be logical go refinance your home and
borrow as much as possible on it in
order to invest more in non retirement
assets and that brought that up and
she's not willing to do that she's very
hesitant she no no she's unwilling she's
unwilling to refinance your home and
borrow $300,000 on it in order to put
the money in her investments right why
because it's making so much interest
that's illogical right yeah I know okay
there's something wrong with her
argument she's gonna have to decide
she's got a painter get off the ladder
either we love borrowing money on our
house too in
just in retirement or invest in money
and invest or we don't
can't have an half way it's not logical
right it's bad reporting reader to get
across well I mean it's flawed thinking
I don't have to be loving about it it's
just a discussion with my wife you know
I mean honey you got to decide okay if
you if you're gonna make an argument
about this you got to be willing to go
with your argument and the point I'm
making is the fact that she won't borrow
on the 300,000 borrow 300,000 on your
home in order to invest more says that
she's not giving you the real reason
that's what it says in other words her
arguments not really her reason because
otherwise she'd be going yeah let's
borrow five hundred thousand on this
house and put it all in investments it's
not it's just not a real reason
something else is going on somebody's
gotten in her head somewhere that that's
you know giving her this thought so
here's the thing my proposal would be
this honey let's pay off the house we've
got six hundred and sixty thousand
dollars left I think we'll be okay good
lord you know right and if you hate
having the house paid off in two years I
promise we'll go refinance it and borrow
and put the money back yeah no that's a
good argument I have never had anybody
that paid off their home that hated it
it's like I never had anybody that I
convinced as a Christian and start
giving ten percent that didn't say this
is one of the smartest things I've ever
done to begin to tithe it changed my
life I've never had anybody go Dave you
just you know that suggestion was
absolutely horrid becoming more generous
or becoming debt for your absolutely
horrible Dave Ramsey suggestions you
know I mean right it's it's just a
logical scrud dude so I mean you know I
I you know there's a part of being
loving but there's a part of sometimes
you just argue with your wife you know
because she's wrong Wow I mean Sharon I
listen to
she's a proverbs 31 woman she's a
virtuous woman so I want to listen to a
virtuous woman so I have no lack of gain
scripture says and so but there's some
times that Sharon is making an argument
it has nothing to with virtue she's just
being angry hillbilly and so I gotta
call her out on that I'm going hey angry
hillbilly we're not this is not the
virtuous wife we're having a discussion
with you you're just pissed off and
we're not doing that and so you know you
and I'm not picking on your wife I'm
talking about mom doing my personal
laundry on the air here to let you know
I'm human but but the point is every
this every couple has a discussion on
this and if some if she were doing
cocaine I'm not having a loving
discussion with her about her cocaine or
freaking stopping it you know now this
isn't cocaine but there's this is just
illogical there's no reason for it so
pay off the house and if you hate it
darling in two years we'll go refinance
it and borrow even more on the house if
you just detest being debt-free and I've
never had one go back on that so try
that maybe it'll work I don't know